So now we are in a really great position.
We have an equation that actually has
numbers in it. However, it's time for me
to make a confession. I'm really, really
lazy. I'm just super tired of writing out
all these words in our equation. I know
that it is important first to keep in mind
what are equations about. But I think that
we can remember that. Even if we do take a
few shortcuts as long as I remember what
belongs in this spot of the equation or
what this part of the equation means. I
might as well rewrite money Grant has left
with something shorter. I've kind of
already taken a few shortcuts already. For
example, I've used a dollar sign instead
of writing out the word money. And I used
a pound sign instead of writing out the
words, number of. So it's okay to take
shortcuts, as long as they make sense to
us. So the thing that I decide to replace
these words with could be, really whatever
we want. A single letter, or a single
symbol. I think I'm going to use a,
square. We can do a similar thing for
number of months over here. Going with the
geometry theme, I am going to call this,
triangle, instead of number of months. So
what I'm really doing here then, is
assigning a new name, to each of these
parts of the equation. We're going to say
that square equals money Grant has left,
and triangle equals number of months. So
let's rewrite this top equation up here.
Using our new symbols. Here are four spots
that we need to fill in to make our new
equation. or rather, our modified version
of the original equation. Please pick from
the buttons under each slot to select
which number or symbol belongs in the box
above. Good luck.